- (Laughs) Have I ever done any modeling?
(laughs) No.
I'm a little nervous
about this photo shoot.
I don't do anything really,
like, focused on myself,
so the fact that it's going
to be about me is a little...
- I'm excited.
I get to pose with an animal.
- I don't know how I'm
about to take off my clothes
for the camera right now, but here we go.
- I expect this experience
to be a little uncomfortable.
Having somebody do your
hair and makeup, and then
I have no idea, just fashion-wise,
what I'm going to look like.
- I'm excited.
I'm excited.
I am an Instagram model
in my head, so I'm ready.
And, you know, I love me some Beyonce,
so I'm ready to tap into that part of me.
- My usual makeup routine
is done in my car.
I drop my son off at school, and then
I head to work and do my
makeup at the stoplights.
- Since I got pregnant,
it's a lot more minimal
than it used to be.
I've been dealing with a
lot of pregnancy rosacea.
Every time I put sunscreen on,
it makes my face freak out.
Rashes on my face and just a
ton of weird stuff going on.
- During the day, if I'm at home,
splash water on my face,
and ponytail or whatever up.
Oh, God.
Every time a celebrity has
a baby and I look at them
afterwards, I'm like, "No.
"Mm-mm, no no no no no.
"It's impossible."
- I think if you happy, if
you're proud of your body,
go ahead and show off, but
I do think they need to
tell the truth and be
like, "Yeah, I had a chef.
"I had a trainer.
"I got some of this fat
sucked up out of my body."
- It piles on a lot of added
pressure to get your body back
as soon as you deliver, basically.
(low-key music)
- I'm really awkward with posing.
I don't feel 100% comfortable
in front of a camera.
I just want somebody to just pose me
in every photo, if they could.
- [Offscreen Director] Use the arms.
Put shoulders back at the same time.
- (Laughing) Oh my God.
- It hurts the hip a little. (laughing)
I'm like, yes, hips!
- [Offscreen Director] Relax your face.
Yeah, and kind of look at me
without furrowing your brow.
- Okay.
You know, I knew that I'd be
able to pull something off
with this, but I am glad,
after seeing the shots,
that I really did, because
sometimes you envision
in your mind what you think your picture's
gonna look like, then you realize,
"Oh no, I look like a piranha."
It was nice to see the picture and see,
"Oh yes." (snapping)
"Yes, bitch, you are a smash."
- It was absolutely amazing.
The whole process was just so neat,
getting my hair and makeup done,
and just feeling completely pampered,
and look at this little guy! (clucking)
- I feel pretty good, surprisingly.
Look at this hair, you guys.
Look at this hair, what?
- It wasn't what I expected.
It was a unique experience.
It takes a lot of work and
effort to look so effortless.
- Getting my body into that
position was very unnatural,
and it kind of made my
hips hurt a little bit.
I have a lot more appreciation for models,
I'll tell you that.
- I feel like I was wearing
my pregnancy like a gown.
- The first time I looked
at myself afterwards,
it really was one of those "damn" moments.
It was a pretty nice
feeling, like, that's me.
- Looking at the photos
after they were taken
and seeing that sexiness come through was
very interesting for me because
I don't see myself as sexy.
That's something that, you know,
you do when you're younger,
and you don't have kids,
and you're not married,
and it's like, once you
have kids, you're a mom.
It was kind of cool to
let that side out and
try to emulate a very sexy woman
who happens to be a mother.